digamos que usted es una persona soltera
y que tiene un ingreso de 50 mil dólares
anuales vamos a calcular cuál es el
salario neto que usted va a tener
después de pagar sus impuestos federales
en otro vídeo vamos a calcular cuáles
serán los impuestos estatales si es que
usted vive en una ciudad que cobra este
tipo de impuestos lo primero que tenemos
que encontrar es cuál es nuestro ingreso
al que se le va a aplicar el impuesto
esos 50 mil dólares son nuestro ingreso
salario en bruto para encontrar nuestro
ingreso a qué se le aplica impuestos
tenemos que quitarle a esto nuestras
deducciones y exenciones aquí no vamos a
entrar en este tema con mucho detalle
vamos a suponer que ustedes son una
persona normal y que nada más tienen
este tipo de deducciones no realizan
demasiadas donaciones a la caridad o
algún otro elemento de deducción ustedes
tienen la deducción estándar y si son
personas solteras de quien no dependen
nadie más que ustedes mismos tendrán la
exención personal si tú
alguna pareja o hijos podrían tener una
extensión mayor aquí la clave en la
deducción y en la exención es que estas
son deducibles de sus impuestos éstos
reducen el ingreso al que se le aplican
los impuestos así que comenzamos con
nuestro ingreso bruto de 50 mil dólares
y esto le quitamos 6 mil 100 de la
deducción estándar y le quitamos 3 mil
900 de la exención personal así que
nuestro ingreso al que se le aplica en
impuestos federales va a ser 50.000
menos esto que da un total de 10 mil
dólares en deducciones y exenciones
nuestro ingreso al que se le aplica en
impuestos es de 40 mil
dólares ahora de estos 40 mil dólares de
ingresos vamos a ver cuánto se tiene que
pagar de impuestos federales y aquí
tengo una parte del registro de los
tabuladores de impuestos
estas cantidades cambian año con año y
la idea básica de este vídeo es ver cómo
funcionan estos tabuladores aunque éstos
tabuladores pueden cambiar año con año y
muchas personas dicen bueno tengo 40 mil
dólares
entonces caigo en este tabulador de 36
mil 250 87 mil 850 y a este tabulador le
corresponde el 25 por ciento así que el
impuesto sería el 25 por ciento de toda
esta cantidad pero no es así así no es
como funcionan los tabuladores de
impuestos cómo funcionan es que se
aplica el 10% a los primeros 8 mil 925
dólares del ingreso y 15% al incremento
hasta 36 mil 250
y 25 por ciento a la cantidad que está
por encima de 36 1250 vamos a calcular
cuánto es esto sacamos nuestra
calculadora vamos a pagar el 10% de
nuestros primeros 8 mil 925
y además de esto vamos a pagar el 15%
del siguiente incremento hasta los 36
y este incremento es 36 mil 250 menos
8.925
y además voy a pagar 25% en el
incremento que se pone encima de 36 mil
250 nuestro ingreso al que se le aplican
impuestos es de 40 mil y a esto le
restamos 36 mil 250 para ver la cantidad
que cae en este tabulador vamos a
verificar escribimos todo correcto
si escribimos todo bien y nos da 5 mil
928 puntos 75 vamos a redondear lo a 5
mil 929 dólares así que el impuesto que
corresponde a esto es 5 mil 929 dólares
y este es el impuesto
impuestos
federal
al ingreso
ahora todavía no terminamos con el
impuesto federal también tenemos que ver
el impuesto fiscal en la parte del
empleado del impuesto fica esto
significa en inglés el acta de la
contribución de seguro federal y esto es
lo que corresponde al pago del seguro
social y el seguro médico y esto es lo
que paga el empleado de hecho lo voy a
escribir completo porque puede
significar para el empleador o para el
empleado esto de aquí es del empleado la
porción que paga el empleado el
empleador o la empresa paga la otra
mitad de estos impuestos para el
empleado el seguro social es el 6.2 por
ciento y el seguro médico desde el 1.45
por ciento
aquí no aplica ni exenciones ni
deducciones por lo que esto va a afectar
nuestra cantidad de salario original
vamos a calcular cuánto es esto son 50
mil
punto 0 62 que es el seguro social
más punto 0 1 45 por ciento de el seguro
médico
y nuestro impuesto fiscal es de 3 mil
825 así que lo que nos corresponde pagar
de fica
es 3 mil 825 dólares
y digo que es su parte de este impuesto
porque su empleador
también va a pagar
su parte correspondiente de este
impuesto esta parte sale de su salario
su empleador pagará otros dos mil 825
dólares que básicamente ustedes nunca
verán o nunca recibirán esto se paga
directamente al gobierno y ahora si
tenemos todos los impuestos que vamos a
pagar todo esto saldrá de nuestro sueldo
y sacamos la calculadora para hacer esas
operaciones sumamos estas dos cantidades
3.825 más cinco mil 929 que nos da un
total de nueve mil 754 dólares lo
escribimos aquí nuestro impuesto total
nuestro pago de impuestos total va a ser
de nueve mil 754 dólares y ya nuestros
50 mil le restamos nueve mil 754
nos queda que nuestro salario neto es de
40 mil 246
así que
40 mil 246 es lo que nos queda después
de haberle quitado todos los impuestos a
nuestro sueldo bruto
al menos los impuestos federales ahora
si ustedes se encuentran en un estado o
en una ciudad donde no se tienen
impuestos estatales esto sería lo que
ustedes tendrían que pagar de impuestos
y eso es lo que les quedarían no habría
más en el siguiente vídeo veremos cuáles
son aquellos impuestos que se tendrían
que quitar a esto si ustedes se
encuentran en un estado o en una ciudad
que tiene impuestos estatales o locales